3 2
1 what happens when two directors depict
the same event using radically different
approaches if you were one of the
viewers of the first nuclear detonation
on July 16th 1945 the time between when
the blinding light of the explosion
first hit your eyes and when you first
heard the sound of that
explosion would have been around 30 to
90 seconds depending on where you were
located so when Christopher Nolan
incorporates this sound delay into
Oppenheimer not only is it accurate and
dramatically effective but it's also a
great example of the use of subjective
perspective in a film while the scene
doesn't play out from the perspective of
a single viewer it is strictly limited
to the perspective of The Observers
themselves while he's showing the
explosion Nolan makes the very
calculated decision to never give us a
more distant objective overview of the
scene like he did here just moments
earlier in the film instead he ground
rounds Us in the immediacy of what the
characters we've been following
throughout the film would have actually
experienced on that day even when we do
see the explosion it's always from the
angle that The Observers would have seen
it from this scene is a great example of
Sonic and visual subjectivity in
film now compare that to
this the way David Lynch depicts the
exact same event in episode 8 of Twin
Peaks the return what we get here is
essenti a 2-minute unbroken take that
flies us directly into the heart of the
explosion down to the level where the
atoms themselves are splitting apart
it's a perspective that's completely
detached from the way any real person
could have experienced this event and
it's a great example of objective
perspective in film I think this scene
was one of the most effective in
Oppenheimer and this scene was one of my
favorites in the entire third season of
Twin Peaks and it's not because I love
watching things blow up it's because of
the way each of these scenes uses
perspective this video is sponsored by
nebula get 40% off the annual plan and
support my work when you sign up today
Lynch is treating the explosion as a
kind of abstract metaphysical event in
his story and so depicting it in a way
no actual real life person could have
experienced it makes sense for the story
he's telling Nolan on the other hand is
telling the story of Oppenheimer himself
so focusing on a more individual
subjective experience serves his story
best I saw barbie the day after
Oppenheimer and my favorite scene from
that film also included a very strong
use of subjective perspective for most
of the film we're following Barbie
narratively in the story but visually
the camera is more clinical objective
and removed emphasizing the studio
artifice of Barbie's World that Greta
Gerwig is intentionally drawing our
attention to but when Barbie leaves this
artificial corporately constructed
fantasy land and for the first time
experiences human emotions in the real
world world look at what happens through
the film's visual
perspective In This Moment it's like
we've suddenly slipped into a different
kind of movie and simultaneously into
Barbie's literal point of view I think
it's a wonderful depiction of these
moments in life where you kind of wake
up to reality the fakeness of the
corporately constructed modern world
just slips away and you see life kind of
as it really is people living
experiencing difficult complicated and
wonderful emotions but the power of this
moment doesn't just come from Greta
gerwick putting us literally in Barbie's
visual perspective she's also using the
shift in the style of film making to
reflect Barbie's emotional internal
state to the viewer the film is taking
on Barbie's emotional perspective
because the film making style is
reflecting Barbie's emotional experience
how Gerwig chooses to shoot and
construct this scene doesn't reflect
reflect Ken's experience another
Barbie's experience or just vaguely the
experience of everyone who's living in
that moment in the world it reflects
Barbie's experience specifically so this
is an example of how not just the
position of the camera and what we're
seeing but the film making style itself
can reflect an emotional perspective
when we think about and talk about
perspective in film most of what we
think of is this when we talk about
objectivity and subjectivity often we're
talking about camera movements or the
position or angle of the camera but
perspective in film runs much deeper
than this and I think it's actually one
of the most powerful tools Cinema has at
its disposal it can be the emotional
heart of an entire story it can be
shaped by everything from performances
to editing and it starts with how you
write your story but it's also a
complicated idea that I don't think gets
talked about enough so let's try to
untangle some of this what is
perspective in its deepest sense how is
it formed form Med and how does it
impact a film because whether you're a
filmmaker looking to tell the most
effective stories or just a cynophile
looking to better understand what you're
watching I think understanding
perspective and how it's used is a very
important part of understanding
film let's start by talking about this
distinction between objective and
subjective perspective most likely you
kind of have an innate sense of the
difference between these two even if you
haven't thought about it before but how
do we really tell if an aspect of a
movie is objective or subjective here's
how I tend to approach reading the
perspective of a scene or a specific
choice that a filmmaker is making if a
filmmaking decision whether it's a
camera move an edit what we hear or what
we see is motivated by the experience of
one or more characters within the scene
then it's subjective but if how the
scene is shot what we see how the scene
is cut is more neutral or is reflective
of an experience that kind of stands out
inside the experience of any of the
characters within the scene then it's
more
objective these choices can have a huge
impact on how a film or scene feels for
example I think a big reason why for me
Tom Cruz's stunts in Mission Impossible
Fallout go unbelievably hard while the
big stunt in Mission imposs dead
reckoning part one kind of Falls flat is
because of the more effective use of
subjective perspective for the stunts in
Fallout in the Fallout scenes were right
there with Cru and we can see he's doing
it all himself whereas here not only do
we feel much more removed from the
action because of the very objective
perspective but despite the fact that we
know Cruz himself did this jump because
of his reputation and because the film's
marketing really drove that point home
it could have easily been a stunt double
doing this we can't even see that it is
Tom Cruz so you can go to all this work
to plan an incredible stunt and get Tom
Cruz to do it but if you shoot it from
the wrong perspective you kind of
undercut all that work I think it's
useful to think of subjectivity and
objectivity as a kind of spectrum for
example I described this scene in
Oppenheimer as subjective relative to
this scene from Twin Peaks but that
doesn't mean that this scene couldn't be
even more subjective if for example
Nolan had confined the experience of the
scene to what Oppenheimer was
experiencing in another I think very
effective scene in Oppenheimer that's
literally what no
does in this scene we're hearing and
seeing things that only Oppenheimer is
experiencing in his imagination
literally being inside a character's
imagination or mind is about as
subjective as it gets apologies while I
take a quick semantic sidebar here to
avoid some confusion it's important to
note that when I'm talking about
objective and subjective in this essay
The Objective perspective is not
necessarily the more accurate or more
factual perspective if we're talking
about events based on true stories
scenes shot objectively can distort
facts and get them wrong just as much as
scenes shot subjectively and if we're
talking about fictional stories scenes
can be more objective or subjective even
though the whole thing is a fiction
we'll explore this a little bit more
later because there's some interesting
implications here but what you need to
know for now is that subjectivity and
objectivity just refer to how we
perceive the events in the film not
whether or not those events are actually
factual David Fincher's latest film The
Killer is a great example of a tightly
subjective Visual and Sonic perspective
a lot of times film sound is pretty
objective what you're hearing is just a
vague approximation of what the camera
would be hearing or more accurately what
a microphone floating above the heads of
the characters would be hearing but it
is possible for the audience to hear
something that sounds more like what one
of the characters within the scene is
literally
hearing when we hear the music that's
playing just through his earbuds we're
inside his Sonic perspective but that's
not why I bring up this film I bring it
up because it's a great example of
another important kind of perspective
narrative perspective The Narrative
framing of an entire film can also land
somewhere on this spectrum between
subjective and objective a movie like
the Killer is extremely subjective
because for one we're placed inside his
mental headspace through the use of
VoiceOver that essentially sounds like
his internal monologue it's the idle
hours that most often lead a man to ruin
but more importantly the plot
information that we receive as the
audience is entirely filtered through
the information that the killer receives
throughout the film Fincher never Cuts
away from the character of the killer to
to fill us in on a plot point or give us
a piece of information that the killer
himself doesn't have our perspective of
the narrative as a whole is tightly
constrained to the Killer's experience
and knowledge almost the complete
opposite of this would be a movie like
The Big Short mortgage back Securities
subprime loans
tranches it's pretty confusing right so
here's Margo Robbie in a bubble bath to
explain basically here the delivery of
information is completely detached from
whether or not any individual character
is receiving it instead The Narrative
perspective of the film is objective
almost to the point of being more like
an essay or a documentary than a
narrative film another movie that's
almost the opposite from the killer
thematically but which also very
effectively uses a tight subjective
perspective narratively and Visually is
the quiet girl from last year we
experience almost everything in the film
narratively and Visually from the
perspective of the main character who's
a child
and this often comes down to even just
placing the camera at the height of a
child when shooting adults in the film
most movies narrative perspective fall
somewhere between the tight subjectivity
of the Killer and the broad overview
like objectivity of The Big Short a
movie like No Country for Old Men has a
kind of split subjectivity objectivity
each individual scene is very tightly
subjective in each moment we only follow
one character and we only experience
what they're experiencing for example in
this scene where ton Shakur is hunting
down luellin we stay with Luellen's
perspective throughout the scene even
though there have been other scenes in
the movie where we've been following
Anton's subjective perspective but even
though The Narrative Approach in each
scene is very subjective because the
film as a whole follows a bunch of
different subjective perspectives the
entire film has more of an objective
narrative perspective that's built by
sampling all these very tightly
subjective moments what I really want to
drive home as we're talking about this
is that it's not about one perspective
or one use of perspective being best
it's really about understanding which
perspective is going to be best for the
story that you're telling and when to
switch between perspectives if that's
something that will be useful for your
story predictably Hitchcock is going to
come up because he was a master of this
in a story like notorious he tends to
follow pretty tightly with the
subjective perspective of the two main
characters we only really get
information as they get information and
most of the scenes include one of those
characters but in this scene they're
trying to sneak away to a wine seller at
a party to gather some information and
they know that the champagne is going to
run out at a certain point which would
lead to the servant getting more
champagne from the wine seller and their
Discovery Hitchcock could play this
scene entirely in their subjective
perspective but he chooses to cut away
to a more objective narrative
perspective momentarily just to Clue the
audience into what's happening with the
champagne just for the purpose of
creating more suspense dramatic irony or
letting the audience in on a piece of
information that one or more of the
characters doesn't know is essentially a
manipulation of perspective but again
there's no one right path here that's
best sometimes the scene is more
suspenseful when we know that the
character's enemy is hiding behind the
wall and sometimes the scene is more
suspenseful if we stay tightly within
that character's subjective experience
and we're just as in the dark as they
are it's something that filmmakers kind
of have to feel out but if you're not
even thinking about the perspective of
the scene you're going to miss this
entirely when it comes to narrative
perspective whether or not the
perspective is going to be more
objective or subjective and when to
switch between them is not the only
thing you need to think about if you're
using a subjective perspective which
pretty much every film does to some
degree one of the first considerations a
writer needs to make is what perspective
am I going to tell this story from
Martin scorsi was two years into working
on the screenplay for killers of the
flower moon when Leonardo DiCaprio came
to him and asked the question what is
the heart of this story after some
reflection scorsi realized that the
heart of the story he was trying to tell
really lay more with the OS tribe and
less with the FBI agents investigating
the crimes which is what he had been
focusing on so far realizing this they
rewrote the script to include more of
the perspective of the Osage people the
perspective of the men investigating the
crime is a perspective we've seen time
and time and time again in movies and TV
so making this change didn't just make
the story more original and artistically
compelling I think it actually told the
more important Story by focusing on the
perspective that recognizes the
experience of those most directly
affected by these horrific serial
killings and this brings us to a very
interesting consideration when it comes
to perspective in film even though the
script was Rewritten to incorporate more
of the oage perspective technically the
film still focuses more on the villains
than the native perspective and even if
it had focused entirely on the native
perspective technically that native
perspective would have been Martin
scorsese's depiction of his perception
of that perspective which would be
different from that perspective being
depicted by someone who themselves is
within that perspective even though a
film can depict more objective or
subjective perspectives technically both
of those depictions are still from the
perspective of the filmmaker themsel
scorsi is trying to depict this
perspective accurately by Consulting
with and including people from the Osage
tribe in the film making process and I
think it's great that he's including
this perspective rather than excluding
it I'm not saying it's a bad movie
because of this it's one of my favorite
movies of the year I think it's just
important and interesting to make this
distinction between someone depicting
another person's perspective and someone
representing their own perspective if
you're interested in learning more about
this particularly as it relates to
Native perspectives or the killers of
the flower Moon I highly recommend Elias
Gold's video about this on his channel
native media Theory this is a big part
of why representation is itself
important both in front of and behind
the lens the male gaze is a product of
men historically just representing their
perspective of women in cinema white
savior narratives and film are also a
product of perspective being able to see
perspectives that we can relate to as
well as perspectives that are very
different from our own is a huge part of
the power of Cinema and art as a
whole I don't see the world the way most
people do due to the ocul effects of
migraines that I often have sometimes
when I look at the sky I see what I can
only really describe as a film grain
effect and when this isn't happening due
to my mild color blindness where most
people see something like this I see
something a little bit more like this
these two things are a kind of constant
reminder of the subjectivity of my
perception of the world but even if you
don't have these kind of biological
phenomena that I do altering how you see
the world your perspective is still
subjective and unique to you you can put
a 100 people in a room and they all have
literally a different perspective of
that room even if they could stand in
the same place it would have to be at
different times and even if they saw
exactly the same thing they still have
different internal emotional spaces
memories and experiences in the past
that might affect how they experience
what's happening in that room whether
it's a piece of art conversation or
interactions with other people but this
subjectivity is sort of paradoxical
because while those 100 people can have
a 100 unique perspectives there's still
a lot of experience that is universal
there are many things we all feel and
experience in common one of the things I
really love about Cinema something that
keeps me interested in it Beyond just
being something to pass the time is the
unique power it has to bring us into
another perspective sometimes this is
interesting because it's bringing us
into somebody else's subjective
perspective and sometimes it's
interesting because it's allowing us a
more objective perspective than any
person could have in their own
experience perspective is an everpresent
part of life it shapes what we see and
how we see it so tools that allow us to
shift into a more objective perspective
or allow us to Glimpse another
subjective perspective are incredibly
valuable seeing different perspectives
expands our understanding of the world
comparing as many subjective
perspectives as possible is how we get
to an understanding of what objective
reality even is in the first place I
love when a film gets to show me an
experience that I've never had one
that's new to me but it's equally
valuable to me to find myself relating
to and finding commonality with the
perspective of someone in a different
time place or culture every shot film or
scene automatically has some kind of
perspective perspective is just
naturally part of the process of telling
a story in the same way light is just
naturally part of the process of
cinematography but you could just allow
the light to arbitrarily be whatever it
naturally is or you can use light as a
tool to help tell your story the same is
true of perspective you can not think
about it and just shoot your film and
it'll have whatever perspective it has
but I think the greatest films
understand what their perspective is why
they have that perspective and use it
with narrative
intention but it doesn't end with Cinema
while I've been talking about this have
you thought yet about the perspective of
this video obviously I'm presenting my
own perspective narratively but
stylistically it's pretty objective in
delivery but there's also a visual
perspective to the video that impacts
the way it feels with the camera right
here as I'm talking to you hopefully it
feels fairly direct informal and
comfortable but if I were to put the
camera out here in the hallway suddenly
the more
changes how things feel this is the
technique that Benny safy and Nathan
Fielder are using throughout their new
show The Curse where many scenes are
shot with this kind of removed feris
camera peeking around corners and
through doorways the two main characters
in the show are desperate to present a
certain image of themselves to the
outside world and they do this by
performing anytime they're in front of a
camera or someone they want to make an
impression on the show highlights the
absurdity of this couple's attempt to
perform their lives to others by showing
us moments where they're performing and
moments where they're being themselves
in Long unbroken scenes the removed
voyerism the show is poking at an
uncomfortable reality that many of us
know in the back of our minds that
whenever we watch something on reality
TV or on social media whether it's an
Instagram reel or a YouTube video like
this the perspective of the Creator
shapes what you're watching while
there's a beauty that I've talked about
in how Cinema can form and wield
perspectives there are many people who
are invested in passing off their
subjective perspective as objective
reality and filmmaking gives people the
tools to do this shockingly well that
distinction I made at the beginning
where I said that an objective
perspective does not necessarily mean
more factual this is something that
trips us up a lot this is the whole
basis of reality TV reality TV often
distorts and fictionalizes reality just
as much as fictional film can but the
whole genre is based on a style of film
making that makes it look and feel like
you're watching a more objective
perspective like you're watching reality
this same Dynamic is true of social
media it's good media literacy to
realize that every piece of media that
you look at has some kind of perspective
even when something has the impression
of objectivity and doesn't feel like it
has a subjective perspective It
ultimately does to a certain extent the
perspective shaping tools that Cinema
has available come into play even the
moment you turn on your phone camera and
we're all using them without even being
aware of it the tightly controlled
perspective I'm showing you of my office
right now makes me look like less of a
disorganized and messy person than I
actually am this kind of shaping of
reality happens every time we turn on a
camera and choose to point it at one
thing instead of something
else perspective is ultimately an aspect
of media that we can't avoid so we
should be aware of it acknowledge it and
be mindful of how we use
it jet lag is my favorite thing to watch
right now on nebula a sort of reality
travel game show and one of the things
that I like about it is unlike the
reality TV shows you watch on television
in this the participants themselves film
the show there's something so fun and
immediate about the tightly subjective
perspective of How It's shot that makes
it feel like you're really hanging out
with Sam Ben and Adam and their guests
as they chase each other all around the
world there's a quality to it that I
don't think it would have if it was shot
from a different perspective it's a lot
of fun and I watch each episode when it
comes out a week early on nebula you can
also find my usual videos early and
adree on nebula alongside this bonus
video I made about visual perspective in
the Batman that you can find only on
nebula nebula is a streaming platform
that a bunch of other creators and I
created together so that we could create
kinds of content that we wouldn't
normally be able to make on YouTube
having different platforms that we can
put our content on that have different
economic incentives allows us to make
exciting and interesting stuff on top of
our existing YouTube content that we
wouldn't be able to if it weren't for
nebula if you want to see this new
exciting content that we've made and
that we're working on and you want to
support myself and other creators
signing up for nebula is a great way to
do that and if you use my link in the
description below you'll get 40% off the
annual plan it's a really affordable way
to support my work while getting access
to a whole host of nebula Originals
nebula hosts a bunch of different
perspectives on film and television in
addition to mine and if you sign up
using my code it will support my channel
directly right now for a limited time
we're also offering lifetime
subscriptions so you can pay a onetime
fee and get access to nebula for as long
as both you and nebula are around nebula
is a platform I'm really excited to be a
part of so check out the new season of
jet lag that's coming up or my video on
visual perspective in the Batman when
you sign up using the link below or by
clicking the link on the
[Music]
screen